this video is very ambitious i'm hoping
we can get it done on time
[Music]
and you guys might have seen our last
domino video on this channel
that video it was alright it was cool
but that was just a test
for a much larger domino's video
now this video is bigger and better than
the last it's very ambitious
i'm hoping we can get it done on time
and we kind of have to to be honest
because uh
if i don't finish this video i do not go
on vacation do you need a vacation yes i
need a vacation dude my freaking brain
hurts man
my body hurts my lips are chapped man
like when i yawn
the corners of my mouth are cracking
because i'm not drinking enough water
because i'm working so i gotta finish
this video in time oh god
forget about all that stuff right now
okay not important i don't know the
first thing about domino's
so we need to reach out to someone who
does
hey lily thanks for joining us uh on
this little zoom meeting here
is that a crazy background or is that
is that the real deal it is real
i just had a really big fail back here
you see that
oh no how did you keep that from
knocking over all the rest of your
dominoes
so part of it wasn't connected i leave
gaps so if i do not get down it'll just
stop there instead of knocking down the
entire thing
that's called a safety gap right it is
safety gap yeah you know
your dominant terms i learned it from
you you saw the the video that we did in
the corridor crew channel where it's a
little bit like an exploration of the
technology of what we're going to do
and now we've actually written a
corridor video
we've planned out the dialogue for this
video we've planned out the locations
but we only have rough ideas of the
actual design
of the domino run itself in your opinion
what makes
a domino run interesting i think what
makes a domino's set up interesting
is being able to include a variety of
tricks
don't stick with just one trick because
that'll get boring like a line is that's
just so boring to watch
but if you do like structures or like
pac-man
on a wall you can do so much with it
you can build towers hold those as tall
as you can
until it actually becomes unstable
but hopefully you could break physics
and everything and
you can make a setup that's like as tall
as the empire state buildings
that's exactly what we're going to do
literally exactly what we're gonna do so
now i'm thinking like you should do a
castle
using the hexagonal technique which
means it's in pillars of
three dominance and then another three
on top of that which makes like the
hexagon
it's kind of complicated but not really
you'll see it let's take a look at that
maybe that could be our grand tower
well lily thank you so much for chatting
with us i really appreciate you taking
the time to
consult with us very much looking
forward to seeing it
we got five locations all kind of just
like spread throughout downtown a little
bit
so the first obstacle is the fact that
our first scene has a technical element
to it
we have to shoot it carefully with the
shooter very precisely because it is a
very precise
vfx trick we're trying to do get out of
there
oh no we got to get the sam
nothing nothing shows you you're out of
shape more
than when you have to do a bunch of
running in the sun we're both carrying
it at first
but then we have to just have him carry
because we thought we can go faster that
way
how do you feel i feel good minus my
knee
one of the quickest ways to make cg
stuff look real is to
take a custom hdri map here and that's a
high dynamic
range image it's a series of bracketed
images combined together
take a bunch of dark pictures a bunch of
light pictures you put them all together
to give you the ultimate picture once
you have your hdri image and you bring
it into cinema 4d or whatever 3d program
you're using
it's automatic you load it in boom and
it's lighting your world
so every time we go to a new location
and the dominoes are being lit in a
slightly different way
i take a new hdri oh wait
look look look oh
crazy
let's go right now
we have 40 minutes until this part
closes we're crunching so hard right now
and maybe we're having a condo here as
it's doing stuff over here maybe let's
think back to like world's longest
lightsaber which has almost 100 million
views
the world's biggest laser which has like
60 so everything's an intense effect
shot ties in the story
and like we've been holding that really
well with this piece so far
don't you dare say but yeah because i
had a plan for this we have a free
plan we do have some cool stuff but i'm
missing the
guys wait wait it's working and we
enjoyed that for a moment
that moment's missing that's the best
part of this piece is to see the
dominance
and if we don't indulge in that for a
couple shots we're kind of missing out
the whole
value of this piece this is just not the
time to be like hey we need an
extra scene in the script like first off
i totally get it i you know i hate when
sam throws wrenches at me like this too
this happens on almost every shoot or
either sam or nico will come through
and place their executive order on
something to change even though we're in
the middle of it
park closes in five minutes clint five
minutes in five minutes let's get this
last shot let's go
go nico are you ready
here we go and three two one action
guys how far to the gap two miles all
right let's go
oh i can't make two more miles guys oh
come on mr fitness wait no
i've been looking forward to this for
two years and i'm not gonna let some
stupid mistake
take that away from me because look guys
it's working
all right sam so after this part um nico
chases the dominoes
into grand park and it's like a two
minute montage nico filming all the
stuff come on come on we got a crap
wait this is later in the piece but i'm
just a little confused as to
what happened in that scene other than
you guys watching domino's
we're trying to get the domino into
place but it's like hey let's just slow
down a moment and appreciate what we're
seeing
i'll just throw a lob this wrench out
there right now i hate when sam throws
wrenches at me like this too
from a story perspective of you guys
racing to find the middle
and place this domino it like it's a
complete departure it seems like
just simply cutting to cool shots of
dominoes going feels like
you're breaking the flow of the piece a
little hard you guys have some
problems to fix then in that area
because it's really confusing i agree
with you
i i feel like we were trying to balance
three ideas
with what we're looking at here and they
don't work together
i had my initial thoughts on it and it
kind of got flipped upside down
when we were there and then now it's
getting flipped back it's hard having
two bosses
i'm not bossing no i agree with all of
your ideas
i agree the joke isn't working perhaps
now this is that third stage in the
process where it's like you know you
you plan it and then you shoot it and
now you edit it and each stage
rewrites the initial idea what we had
initially was a cool idea it just didn't
translate to what we captured
take your crystal dagger slice up that
ruby heart hold on to it tight
look into it understand it understand
the vision and then
cut this stuff down because there's just
an unwieldy amount of effects but that's
what was shot
all right beating adjourned
this week is our final week to finish
this video if i don't finish this video
by this week i do not go on vacation
[Music]
i need a vacation desperately i need to
go on vacation okay so
i have to finish this video if i don't
finish this video
it's not even an option this video has
to be finished
it's been intense it's been really
intense everyone's been so busy around
the office you know sam and nico been
working so hard on the website that's
coming out
ren has been working on his drone video
you know i've had to head this thing up
and try and get a workflow
set up that makes sense for everyone it
makes sense for the project
every shot needs to be tracked simulated
textured
lit composited
milo is as excited as i am for the
release of this domino's video
so let me show you guys what goes into
one of these vfx shots you're way too
slow
this is the halfway gap shot me and ren
are running this golden domino
to the halfway point if we don't get
there in time the domino run
is gonna fall halfway short we're not
gonna have a world record
we have to make sure that this shot is
trackable
meaning we need to recreate our real
camera
in virtual space so that we can add in
all of these fake dominoes and make it
feel like they actually sit there on the
ground
they aren't going to look good when it
comes to lighting and texturing because
that's the next step
so while we were on set we made sure to
capture an hdri
and then we're using that to light our
scene
so our hdri doesn't have enough dynamic
range to warrant the crisp shadow that a
sun would actually produce
so we're going to drop in a fake one in
post you're referencing the footage
and basing your 3d work and you're
sculpting of the light on the actual
footage
right your footage provides you with
clues to get you closer to a realistic
look
i'll line up the sun so that the shadow
is as long as ren's
shadow is on the ground in real life and
then you add a shadow catcher
it basically makes the plane transparent
except for the shadows
so when you bring it into after effects
it's a transparent layer so
that's basically all i'm doing for the
lighting we've set up the scene we've
tracked it we've lit the scene
but we also want to texture our dominoes
sam's been actually messing around with
some cool stuff so let's check in
in this video there are thousands upon
thousands of dominoes
the creativity we can bring to what are
these dominoes made out of
i think right now is one of the most
exciting parts we're using a
materials collection called the everyday
materials collection
that grayscale gorilla makes and
basically it's a library
of everyday materials like polished wood
concrete metal
plastic candy we're gonna be putting in
easter egg dominoes
throughout these runs one in particular
that i'm pretty proud of
there is a frozen man
inside one of your dominoes oh my
is that god is that carmichael on ice
it's
carmichael on ice oh my god
so we've lit the scene we've tracked the
scene we've modeled the dominoes we've
textured the dominoes now what the heck
did we do with all this well
you have to place your dominoes and
simulate gravity
simulate dynamics to recreate a
realistic domino chain
and my god that has been the hardest
part that has been hands down the
hardest part of this whole thing most
time consuming part of this whole thing
your domino simulation needs to
perfectly line up with your real-life
camera movement and if it doesn't then
you have to go back and keep working it
slow this part down add more dominoes
here make this line a bit
longer space your dominoes a little bit
further apart so they fall slower
it's trial and error like all day given
the month that we've had
to work on this i think we've come up
with some really cool domino structures
that
even some domino folks would be amped
about my goal is to put the o
in domino and not the no in domino you
know
once your dominoes are simulated and it
lines up with your with your camera
track
you're kind of off to the races and all
you have to do from that point is
hop into compositing the compositing
step is where everything comes together
and that's where ren basically combines
your cg renders that me and sam have
been busting out and he makes it blend
seamlessly with the footage that we shot
all the stuff on
and wren he he's got some sleeves man
he's got some really long sleeves
multiple sleeves
and he's got a lot of tricks up them
i've worked on this video for like
two and a half months it feels like two
and a half months jesus
i'm glad sam and ren has found some free
time because i can't do this on my own
i'm not superman
i need water
[Music]
clint clinton clinton
oh huh is the domino video done
yeah i think so good time oh my god
i'm late i'm late for my vacation dude i
gotta go
the video the video is actually done you
guys can go watch it on youtube.com
corridor please go watch it and support
you know i spent a lot of time on this
blood sweat and tears went into
finishing this video for you guys so go
check it out
leave a comment let me know what you
thought about it dean
[Music]
i'll see you in a week